i have to say uh you love to come on and
uh you're always
shocking me you're always saying
something that shocks me but i do admire
how forward and honest you are
you believe that women should be forward
and honest
uh you know when they're interested in a
guy they should just
say what they're thinking isn't that
true yes because men have been so
forward and honest for such a long time
yes bosses would tell their secretaries
like wear a shorter skirt how come i
can't walk around be like wear
sweatpants all the time so i can see
your dick print
when men wear toy pants dick print is
what it's called yes
when men wear sweatpants they show you
what they're
carrying around and it's a real treat
conan you gotta go to like a basketball
game on a saturday
and after that why do i have to see it
why do you think i want to see it i
don't know dicks or treats
i'm in there we go so uh so you
it's really i didn't even realize it was
called a dick print i did print a nice
dick print you're like oh okay okay
so uh so that's what you like you like
guys in sweatpants it's one of my
favorite things
oh my god and instagram is full of it
yeah
my explore page is just sweatpants on
men
yeah instagram has a great algorithm and
it serves me what i want
you can probably get to the point where
you can identify a guy just by looking
at the pants
[Applause]
that's why i look first then i look for
a ring all right